oh and welcome to dear Hank and John or
as I prefer to think of it Dear John and
Hank it's a comedy podcast where me and
my brother John we answer your questions
give you two beasts advice and bring you
all the week's news from both Mars and
AFC Wimbledon hey John how you doing hey
we're both very tired I know that we're
often tired when we record the pod but
like right now I I've been tired for a
few months and Turtles all the way down
is finally it's it like I'm in the last
hours of it belonging to me ya know like
in like I don't know like 200 hours or
so or maybe a hundred fifty hours it
will never belong to me ever again
and it's belonged to me for like six
years so I have chosen to spend these
last several hundred hours with Turtles
all the way down awake and there are
times when I have regretted that
decision but I also can't seem to make
any other decision how are you I'm good
you know I feel bad that I haven't read
your book because you sent it to me
about a week ago and I still haven't
read it and but I do hope that you
understand that I can't do anything yeah
i the the the candle is burning at both
ends and it will not last the night but
are there are there could you have a
candle and he like split off the middle
part into like a third end and white
that one too
I believe that would actually give you
four ends and if so Hey immediately
light all four of them because that's
the kind of person he is no I've
actually have made my my candle into
like the the weapon from the movie crawl
and it spins really fast so it's extra
oxygenated so all five ends can can burn
really fast
is that a movie I'm just I'm never I'm
not familiar with the movie but is it a
movie in which the krill that blue
whales eat to turn evil no you know
that's disappointing no in fact I
couldn't I can't even tell you very
anything about the movie crawl I just
remember I watched it when I was a child
on television and I was so in love it's
just it's I was it was the best thing
it was and I should probably watch it
again so I know how bad it is but I
really liked it well no hurry on reading
my new book but quick reminder to our
listeners they can read it on October
10th and get a signed copy too by going
to probably signed Turtles calm the
number one web site on the internet
right now it's blowing up one of one of
the things I did this weekend that I
actually quite enjoyed was was hanker
fishing
almost 5000 pieces of paper 3000 almost
3,000 oh jeez God
wow there's you do what you do in this a
lot I did not I did not finish I've not
done yet but I'm like two thirds of the
way done and it's not an insignificant
task John no and that's only I will
remind you one and a half percent of the
total signatures so I feel bad for only
doing one and a half percent well I also
feel bad I wanted to send you a second
box but you said no I know I feel bad
but that doesn't mean that here's the
thing that you gotta know just cuz you
feel bad doesn't mean you have to do
something like I can I can I can feel
guilt and be like I it's really too bad
that I'm not doing this thing and I feel
bad that I'm not doing it but also I'm
not going to because I feel better about
not having to do that thing alright I
think that's actually a pretty good
transition to our first question we're
skipping the short poem because I read I
I recited half of that Edna st. Vincent
Millay poem so we're good on the short
poem front we're moving on okay this
question comes from Matt and it involves
you know something that's that's
difficult that you might or might not do
Dear John and Hank what is the largest
terrestrial animal you would feel
comfortable fighting in hand-to-hand
combat likewise what is the smallest
terrestrial animal you think would best
you
aardvarks and armadillos Matt I think
that there are times when my cat could
take me yeah I mean I actually I was
thinking that as well Hank like there's
a there's a coyote in my backyard I mean
it's not really a backyard there's a
coyote in the forest behind my house and
I see it sometimes and it probably
weighs like thirty pounds and I see it
and I think we both know
that if you're hungry I'm dead you could
totally take a coyote I mean I think I
know I couldn't I think like a like I'd
have a hard time like like fighting and
winning against a porcupine right cuz
like yep what am I gonna do like a like
where am I gonna punch you what how am I
gonna strangle a porcupine like I'm like
I might be able to get it get away
without any trouble but I don't feel
like I'm gonna win similarly I don't
think I could kill a skunk um I think
the smell would overpower me I would
lose consciousness and the skunk would
slowly eat me over the course of three
days so John that definitely the the
largest terrestrial animal I could kill
yeah it's probably a tortoise like a
Galapagos tortoise I would just hold it
and preventing it from prevented from
getting food yeah 100 pounds but like
there's a number of sizes they would may
be a juvenile I feel like you and a
Galapagos tortoise you'd probably win
but it would take like 14 days of
hand-to-hand combat before a winner was
finally declared you know what I mean
John I met an armadillo recently a
three-banded armadillo' there they can
fully enroll meaning they can become
100% ball and they can just roll down a
hill one of the few animals that can do
that I think may be the only vertebrate
and and what I found out is that in
addition to being able to fully enroll
this the three brother armadillo will
close almost all the way and leave a
little gap intentionally so that a
predator will put its nose into that
little gap to try and get it and then it
closes all the way and it totally like
like but like basically bite but with
its armor plates the nose of the of the
predator which is and this happened to
my friend Jesse who runs animal wonders
and takes care of all these exotic
animals and her too she survived her
finger was stuck inside the armadillo
for like a half an hour but she lived
she did survive so we could take an
armadillo or at least Jesse could yeah
yeah I mean do I have any tools I guess
I don't because then No
or no like no weapons no punching no
punching but no like baseball bats or
anything it's just what can could you
take down a coyote with your arms and I
don't think I could all right god I got
another question it's from Katrina who
asks dear Hank and John my summer job
consists of scanning and destroying old
files at a law firm during this process
I have to remove all of the staples from
documents before I feed them through a
scanner
I have come to accumulate many mugs full
of used staples the summer is only
halfway done so more will be added to
the collection it feels wrong to just
throw away all these staples what would
you suggest I do with them sometimes
paper clips and fasteners Katrina I mean
you definitely have to melt them down
into like bullets or something
you've got to melt them down into
something awesome well what is a staple
made of well it's that's actually much
more of a hank question than it is a
John question well John it just so
happens that inside of my brain without
googling this at all modern staples for
paper staplers are made from zinc plated
steel wires glued together and bent to
form a long strip of staples so there's
that sounds like something that you just
already knew and not at all like you're
currently on the Wikipedia page for
staple and then in parentheses fastener
because there's more than one kind of
staple yeah
staples the store yeah there's
presumably some other kind of staple
where's the disambiguation paid for
staple there are surgical staples
there's the the staple right the
medieval right of certain German ports
to require merchant vessels to unload
and display their goods for sale for a
certain period off in three days
there's the statue est sure there's
there's Vince staples the American
rapper born in 1993 yeah there's the the
famous American politician King staples
who was a Republican member of the
Wisconsin State Assembly that seems like
a very low bar to have to jump over to
get a Wikipedia page there is of course
the Christian Post hardcore band staple
because apparently there are Christian
post hardcore bands
I mean that's actually great that's
great
that's wonderful that there is a
Christian post-hardcore band I wonder if
there's a Christian pre hardcore band oh
and of course there's staples Canada
which is like staples but it's in Canada
oh oh I thought that was a name of a
town if that maybe Staples just bought
oh god that's a great idea Hank speaking
of which we have we finally gotten to a
point in our lives where we could buy
winner South Dakota the town that is
exactly equi distant between our two
homes you know probably dot it's a
property value is surprisingly expensive
we gotta we gotta buy that McDonald's we
gotta buy the Holiday Inn Express and
Suites winner and then all do they have
a Holiday Inn Express if you have a
Holiday Inn Express Wow all right yeah
we definitely can buy Holiday Inn
Express is okay like that that that is a
thriving town if it has a Holiday Inn
Express let's get back to this question
of the staples yeah so you're gonna get
some zinc and you're gonna get some
steel and and zinc is mostly what
pennies are made out of so you could
send that off to the penny pleat people
and they could make pennies out of it oh
yeah that's a great deal II probably you
get like a third of a penny out of those
staples I think that what you should do
is you should freak out the attorneys
that you work with I think you should
start spelling stuff out in staples at
night when they're at home on their desk
and then in the morning they'll be like
why does it say put $50 in the scanner
or I will tell your secrets in staples
on my desk right good good good is there
some kind of like fashion options here
that's a great idea you got it built
make a chainmail sweater at a station
that's it
you make the chainmail sweater out of
staples no one will mess with you if you
have a chainmail sweater also it will be
impossible to take off because the
staples will not loop completely and
they will just bind to whatever you're
wearing underneath so furthermore if you
had a chainmail sweater then you could
take a coyote yeah definitely no I think
you could take a coyote with or without
a chainmail sweater John I just think
that you know properly motivated know
but I could definitely take a coyote if
I had a chainmail sweater on if for no
other reason than it would make me feel
super confident I I feel like it's
really nice to hear that they're using
some paper clips and fasteners because
of course those can be reused a staple
is just a one-time thing and I you know
also when you have a big stack of
documents it's not just like the hand
stapler like you like that the swingline
that they got an office space but like
this like a like it's almost like a
staple gun and it's like shook and it
goes through like it could you could go
through you could bind like two pieces
of wood together with that thing
I've been using a nail gun recently for
a home-improvement project and oh my god
like what I mean I am done with hammers
it is over between me and hammers nail
guns are amazing I'm sure that like
eventually I will nail my finger to a
piece of wood and I will be like maybe
hammers aren't so bad after all
but right now man I am loving life with
a nail gun let's move on to another
question Hank all right I feel like we
did a really good job Katrina the short
answer is you're gonna have a couple
mugs of staples for the rest of your
life so no you're gonna make a chainmail
sweater and it's gonna be amazing this
question comes from Sarah who writes to
your children Hank why is it that when
something is spinning quickly such as a
fan a wheel on a car or a fidgets
spinner the object itself appears to be
spinning in the opposite direction than
it is actually rotating Veta to in Sirte
Moore's SART Aseema Sarah I believe that
means life is uncertain death is certain
but I'm just guessing John I don't know
the answer to this question I know the
answer to this question it's finally
happened it's finally happened there is
a question about science that Hank does
not know the answer to what which
happens all the time but he's not
pretending to know the answer and I do
know the answer you sure that you're not
wrong I'm pretty sure that I'm not wrong
okay I know why I can't okay why cameras
don't I know I camera see them go
backwards they're going and slowly yes
it is because our eyes are not actually
that dissimilar from cameras it's
because the frame rate in our brain is
not infinite we see individual images we
do not see motion and then we create
motion with our brains
and that makes things weird when they're
moving really fast I mean I know I I am
surprised that our that our eyes work
that way if they indeed do and I look
forward to to Emile's from people
telling us whether or not John was right
about that what I'm sure I can't wait
for the Corrections they will be Legion
okay hey how about this one from Emmitt
John who asks dear Hank and John okay so
I may have made an impulse purchase of
527 glow-in-the-dark stars from Amazon
they were only three dollars so don't
judge me
well gazing up into my homemade galaxy
however I couldn't help but wonder how
the Stars are able to shine how do
things glow in the dark space is vast
and mysterious Emma okay so my theory is
that glow in the dark stuff absorbs
light and then spits it back out when
it's dark well it spits it back out
whether or not it's dark but kind of yes
so there so you know like some some
things you look at like some markers or
pieces of paper and they like for some
reason they're they like seem to be it's
not just the color they have they're
also like throwing out like like more
color than you feel like they should or
at a different or like a different color
than you feel like they should this is
especially obvious when you use black
light so you have a black light and
you're shining the black light on like a
white thing and suddenly it looks like
that thing is glowing there's like way
more light coming out of the shirt than
there is going into it it appears right
right
yes yes I'm familiar with this so what
is in fact happening is that there is
light going into that shirt that you
can't see and then it's being
reradiating or not radiates I guess but
it's being it's being it's being read
it's like it's it is absorbed by the
atoms in the shirt and then it is read
in a different wavelength so it goes in
electrons do some magic stuff and then
when the electrons do their magic stuff
it cut like that the FO another photon
comes out and that photon is at a
different light wavelength that you can
see in a similar way a
the when you have glow-in-the-dark thing
the photon go in and then it messes with
the electrons and then the photon comes
out but there's a delay it doesn't
happen immediately it happens a bunch
and it happens all the time and it
happens in sort of a curve from like you
know the moment when you take the light
away is the most photons coming out and
then slowly as time goes on fewer and
fewer of the electrons earlier of the
photons come out so that that's
basically what's happening
I got a huge I don't know a huge amount
about that but but when light hits a
thing it can change the energy level of
a photon or electron going around the
the atom and then when it drops back
down to its old energy level which will
eventually happen sometimes immediately
and sometimes after a fair bit of time
it will release another Photon
well that is interesting good I'm glad
I'm so I'm glad I know that it turns out
I was basically right all along and also
to the extent that I wasn't right I
don't really understand let's move on to
this other question from anonymous who
writes hello brothers green my husband
and I just found out that we are
pregnant
hmmmm you're pregnant he is excited he's
pleased or yes we're very excited but
would like to wait to tell friends and
family until the second trimester when
the risk of losing the baby is lower
however friends and family have already
been asking us about our plans to have
children and some have even asked us
directly if I am pregnant those people
should be banned they should thought
about they should not be allowed anymore
I am sure that these questions are
well-intentioned but I still find it
hard and awkward to respond no duh yeah
I signed off anonymous this happened to
us I don't know if this happened to you
it probably did I probably did it for
God's sakes I'm sorry if I did this
happened us all the time because like
Sarah wouldn't be drinking wine and yeah
it would be like why aren't you drinking
wine are you pregnant and Sarah would be
like I don't want to talk about it it's
like well now I either have to lie or
tell you the thing that I obviously
didn't want to tell you yeah and you
there are there are good reasons why
people don't want to talk about
pregnancy in the first trimester and
that is or whenever it's shouldn't be up
to anybody but you when you tell people
that you're pregnant and who you tell
and it is super annoying to ask and it's
incredibly invasive and don't ask yeah
yeah I mean especially like the thing
that there's I mean who so the serious
note like some people will try very hard
and for a very long time to get pregnant
and camped and then you're kind of
bringing up a sore subject some people
have you know repeated miscarriages and
then you're bringing up that and that's
no fun for them to deal with so in
general yeah it's sort of like it's a
it's it's I understand why you want to
bring it up and why it's funny and why
we why we do it but like there's also
this like it's kind of like you go there
and 90% of the time or 99% of the time
it's like fun and like a cute fun thing
that happened even if you are pregnant
you're like okay fine I'll have to tell
you that I'm pregnant in that and that
you've uncovered my mystery and it's not
that big of a deal but like there's that
small percentage chance that it's like a
really like you're bringing up a super
sore subject and that maybe we don't
like and that they should be up to that
person whether or not they're gonna
bring that up
so also it's not ninety or ninety nine
percent of the time it's way closer to
75 percent of the time I mean something
like a quarter of all pregnancies end in
miscarriage so it's just there is no
reason to bring it up yep
as far as I'm concerned that's that I'm
sure I'm a little bit biased in that but
yeah your responsibility
you you should feel free to lie to those
people would be my answer because I
think they have put themselves in the
position where they are gonna get lied
to yeah and then when you tell them
later they won't be like oh my god
you're a terrible person for lying to me
you know or if they are you can just be
like well that's strike two one board
one more chance and you're out of the
friend bucket this is the bucket where a
key
my friends and your your your leaking
out the bottom my bud I think I think
that's a wonderful image that we should
use more often I think we should tell
people you're about to leak out of my
friend bucket if you don't watch out
mister I got a friend bucket and it's
got holes in it maybe like what can we
do to patch up our friend buckets John
so they're not as leaky I feel like
actually my friend bucket is not leaky
at all I haven't lost a friend in like a
decade now I will say in my early 20s I
used to lose a lot of friends but I
haven't I haven't like had a friend
dumped me in years which maybe it's like
maybe you got a bucket and and and you
it's not leaking but you're like sort of
going through your life and it's
sloshing around a little bit so when you
have your bucket super full of friends
some are gonna fall out it's just gonna
happen and that's okay but when you're
like 37 and you have like two friends
left should be a little more careful
with this thing and also it's harder for
them to fall out because yeah maybe I
mean I think that also might be one of
those places where like the metaphor
itself is limited in how far you can
take me
possibly who knows it could be it could
be but there's a hole in the bucket dear
Liza and I've only got one friend left
all right
let's go to this other question from
Renee who writes dear green brothers my
best friend and I shared an apartment
while in college and during that time I
gave her access to my Netflix account
uh-oh somebody's leaking at the bottom
of the friend bucket she has now
graduated and while I was happy to let
her use the accountant while we lived
together I feel like it is time for her
to get her own I pay for Netflix for my
whole family myself my three siblings my
parents and my grandmother and having
her used the account adds another person
to an already limited server she also
uses my profile and fills the queue with
shows I have no interest in watching oh
come on don't put stuff in the queue
that is one of the worst things I've
ever heard in my whole life oh my god I
it's not your account you can like it's
what like your being done a tremendous
$9 a month favor $10 a month favor now
I'm shivering and you just you're
abusing that privilege
Renee you need to drill a hole in that
friend plumbing you have to if you are
using someone else's net for
account you have to it and by the way I
include my own spouse in this like when
I watch Netflix as Sara I have to be an
absolute ghost don't rate anything don't
queue anything don't list anything just
be as close to a ghost as I can be and
that's that's my we're married you know
if you have separate Netflix profiles of
course we have separate Netflix profiles
we don't have identical on France it
says who's watching Netflix the moment
you log on to Netflix and I say me or
Sarah or kids and the kids I mean oh my
god the things my children watch on
Netflix if I have to watch there's all
these Netflix kids shows with no words
in them Hank I don't you're not familiar
with this yet but like there's the show
Oscar's Oasis that I guess is like you
know it works in every country because
there's there's no language it's
fascinating the stuff that they choose
to watch when they get a hold of Netflix
like before we wake up on a Saturday
morning but anyway yes Sarah and I have
separate Netflix accounts because we
watch different kinds of things okay we
have like when we watch Netflix together
we can watch on either person's Netflix
account but when watching stuff alone I
don't want to have you know my bucket
poisoned by all the weird you know crime
procedurals that Sara likes
I mean Kathryn and I have the exact same
interest John I find that weird I indeed
we do not and I guess is that less that
is that what's confused by us they're
like who are these people that like both
house of cards and The Vicar of Dibley
is The Vicar of Dibley a real show yeah
oh my god IV that that show sounds like
the best made-up show it's like you walk
it to the BBC offices you sit down in
front of you know the person who makes
all the BBC shows you sit down you look
them dead in the eye and you say The
Vicar of Dibley and they just like pull
out a stamp that says yes here is our
here is our highest budget $300 go bake
it you
[Laughter]
yeah they order like 250 episodes yeah
after you say the victim doesn't even
like the Vicar of Dibley that much
mostly mom likes that show she watches
it on our Netflix account oh man
anyway point being Renee obviously you
need to have a talk with your best
friend about putting things in your
Netflix queue that is I mean it's if
it's oh it's not cool it's a little like
I don't understand when you were living
together why that person had to have
access to your Netflix account at all
it's just it's in the TV like did you
have to she did she need to watch it on
her computer and I guess so you can
watch it like different things at
different
oh man but then you then you're stuck
honestly I would go to the best friend I
would go to the best friend and I would
say I will pay $50 for your first five
months of Netflix on your own so that
you can build your own queue and I get
your weird stuff out of my queue so I
don't have to keep watching the victim
and it is it is after like it is best
friend though like you can't you're not
gonna unfriend this person do you think
there's anybody with a Vicar of Dibley
tattoo I mean there's only one way to
find out Jon I know hold on it's a race
it's a race get me the Google Images oh
wow oh my god that is a Vicar of Dibley
tattoo oh and it's a big smile it's a
big dip we smile what's going on the
patreon Oh daddy oh man I want to go
back in time to the moment before I saw
The Vicar of Dibley tattoo oh that is
it's not it is not a small tattoo don't
you think it's different like I've been
very lucky that people have been willing
to put stuff that I wrote in quotations
on their body but so far as I know
there's no tattoos of like my face I
think it's different if it's a tattoo
like that is a tattoo of the Vicar of
Dibley 'he's smiling face with the
and the the yeah you know priests
priests outfitting everything yep oh boy
oh boy
so yeah man I really yeah John Green
face tattoo now let's just you with
peanut butter on your faces all I got
well there you go there you go
I think I there's something extremely
intense about having somebody's uh face
on your body for the rest of your life
well the Vicar of Dibley is a very good
show it's very funny and uh and and I I
appreciate a super fans in all stripes
whether whether you're you know welcome
sending in clips for for for weird
nerdfighter projects or whether you're
tattooing the figure of Dibley on your
bicep I think if you like The Vicar of
Dibley so much you know what I think you
should do no I think you should get a
Vicar of Dibley tattoo I don't have any
tattoos John and I know it would be a
great first tattoo that people be like
so why did you pick the Vicar of Dibley
and you'd be like oh is for a goof on my
podcast
I'll be like I've never actually seen
the program I wanted to pick a piece of
media that I liked but didn't love
representative of like they're like I
don't want to be to all anything so I
this is more of a celebration of sort of
liking stuff more than a celebration of
this particular show yeah it came down
between The Vicar of Dibley and NCIS Los
Angeles but no I have never seen I don't
even know if it's real
speaking of which today's podcast is
brought to you by the Vicar of Dibley
The Vicar of Dibley now on Netflix yes
it is it is and also available wherever
British people are it's just like they
walk into a room and it just happens
this this podcast is additionally
brought to you by 527 glow-in-the-dark
stars available apparently on amazon.com
for 3 bucks and of course today's
podcast has also brought to you by
fighting to the death against a coyote
fighting to the death against the coyote
I'm not totally confident
ya know unless you got that deal is you
got that chainmail made out of staples
yeah and finally John I don't know if
you know but this podcast is sponsored
by an actual
answer we have a real sponsor again we
don't lay sack blaze Hank I use back
plays so I feel like I can actually talk
about it well I mean basically what we
have to say is your data is valuable and
precarious yeah I used to email myself
at the end of every day the document
that I was working on that eventually
became Turtles all the way down and then
I found out about Backblaze where for
$5.00 a month it does that exact same
thing except with all of your files not
just with the one file it backs up
pictures documents everything it's $5 a
month it's unlimited backup and it is it
works really really well it has a mobile
app it can restore stuff by email it's
great yeah
backs up not just documents but music
photos videos drawings projects
everything you do on your computer there
are a number of things that could happen
to your computer John it could get hit
by a meteor it could catch fire your
house could catch fire you could leave
it I feel like either Neath a chair on
an airplane like I did and and all those
there's some baby pictures that I'll
never get back John back place I did not
BEC list yup Hank that's because you
didn't have back place you'd go to back
place calm slash Dear John to learn more
it's $5 a month again unlimited backup
back place.com slash Dear John that is
the only URL that you should use if you
want to go to vac places that come / -
you're Hank that's also available but
I'm not gonna fight this one because
John actually uses it and I haven't yet
but I'm seriously considering signing up
because I freaked my [ __ ] hey Hank Hank
when you sign up please go to Backblaze
comm slash dear John
we'll see what what choice I make you
can't I can't wait I really hope I oh
man I really hope you use I have really
hope you use my URL that would make me
so happy Hank um when I answer not the
question because I actually feel like I
might be able to help with this one
probably not but maybe this question
comes from Dinah who writes Dear John
and Hank I've come to realize I have a
major social anxiety disorder and it's
really starting to back me into a corner
then they talk about going to an
expensive therapist for six months and
feeling like they weren't making
progress
and then there are a number of phone
calls I have to make an email I have to
send summer intimidate
others are so simple they shouldn't
intimidate me but I'm just avoiding all
of it and I know I am gonna keep doing
and I feel like I'm in such a rut I
don't know if I should see another
therapist or if it's just time to grow
up
I don't know this problem is only
getting worse your dubious advice would
be appreciated Dinah
or possibly Dina I'm not very good at
pronunciations so this is something that
everybody experiences not just people
who have anxiety problems right like
Hank you definitely experienced needing
to send an email and not being able to
yes in fact I did that all weekend so in
my experience and I want to be clear
that I am NOT a therapist and I do think
that you should see a therapist I think
that you should see somebody who is
experienced in helping with this however
in my experience avoidance does not make
the problem better at least over time it
might make you feel better right now but
it won't it
it will you're right that the problems
tend to get worse when avoidance is the
main strategy so here's my strategy like
in that email you say some of these
emails are so simple they shouldn't
intimidate me what well but they do so
it doesn't matter like should or
shouldn't like don't put that values
judgment on it let's just send those
emails today now actually let's not not
if you're driving
no distracted driving pause the positive
- Wireless get get on get on the
internet Wi-Fi that's all yeah get
Panero Wi-Fi and and break that task up
into what however many little chunks you
need to break it up into in order to get
it done because once you start rolling
down the hill of getting things done and
stopping avoiding them like anything it
gets easier each time and you will love
the feeling of being on the other side
of this and you know that but the only
way to get on the other side of it is to
break it up into tiny little tasks you
open the you open your email program you
go to compose you hit reply whatever and
you look at you
the email to get to the parts that you
need to reply to and then you write the
reply and then you send it just break it
up into constituent parts and once you
start it's gonna feel so much better
because I think in my experience anyway
it's the avoidance it's the sort of
behavioral response to the anxiety that
makes it that I think will make the
anxiety better by like not doing the
thing that's scaring me but often in the
medium and long run makes the anxiety
worse absolutely the case for me I I
mean so much of of the negative emotions
I have are due to you know in part
having signed up to do more than I may
be physical physically capable of but
also you know knowing that those things
are there and not doing it because and
it's it's it's the not doing it that
makes me uncomfortable and unhappy it's
it's not the actual process of doing it
like it like not doing it is holding me
back and from doing it in a weird way
did that make sense right yeah no I mean
a lot of it yeah absolutely it's the the
like dread of not doing something
becomes overwhelming it becomes the
primary experience that you're having it
becomes like it becomes the work you
know like yeah I've found that ever
since I was a kid like I remember being
a kid and my parents saying to me if you
just started this project when you
started worrying about it it would be
over you know like and that's still true
for me like I still it's still something
I struggle with but that that's what
works for me is just like saying this
starts now and we're gonna break it up
into tiny little parts and I'm not gonna
judge myself for it being hard because
it may not be hard for everyone but it's
super hard for me and that's the way it
is before we move on to the news from
Mars and AFC Wimbledon I want to share
an important piece of news okay
Hank you may remember that a few weeks
ago Sarah wrote in to ask about her
husband shaving his head
because he wanted to shave his head to
know what his head looks like and we
answered and we told him that he should
shave his head so there was a head
shaving party good news Sarah reports
that her husband's head does not look
weird shaved and there is an amazing
video of it of the highlights of the
head shaving party because they went all
out it was a full-on head shaving bash
and we are putting that on the patreon
because it is absolutely magnificent
fascist appears to be two people in a
room with with Anna I mean first off you
know that there is a third person
because somebody is holding the care
okay three people save people in the
party Sarah is wearing what appears to
be a formal gown so it is obviously a
pony
Brett John what oh that's working - if
you are confused there is another man
another man has shown up there is okay
there's at least four people one of whom
came pre-pre head shaved or at least pre
bald oh yeah he was yeah he's not hey
Valle didn't advance shave he that just
happened to him over he over years is he
drinking Lacroix mmm
very possibly hold on I gotta zoom in I
got to go to 7:20 and that is a Lacroix
in fact I can tell you right now I
that's a pink Lacroix what is that pink
flavor is it cran-raspberry I've never
had a pink Lacroix I don't think I'm a
real pop so yeah I can confirm that's a
cran-raspberry Lacroix and I can confirm
that this is a party because if there's
Lacroix and for people that is a bash
and I'm looking at his head his head is
now shaved even more than his his face
is and it looks great good in terms of
shape I'm gonna say it's just it's an A+
tink good head shape John's the news
from Mars well it looks like Elon Musk
being you know our only chance to meet
our deadline of 2028 is has scheduled
the the launch of the first test launch
of the Falcon heavy rocket which is the
the rocket that Elon hopes will
we'll take people to Mars and and has
enough oomph to have people on top of it
and get them all the way there and it
will have its first test launch not in
2013 John when it was first scheduled
not in 2014 when it was second scheduled
but indeed this year in November John
he's it has looking for 2027 it's not
good not not good at all
indeed this this test launch might not
even reach space it probably will just
be a super test there there there Mars
mission dates have been pushed pushed
back to 2018 and 2020 it seems unlikely
that they'll hit that you know Elon Musk
is good at getting stuff done but he's
not and I'm not saying that it's like
not saying that's a bad thing I'm pretty
impressed honestly not hitting deadlines
but oh but also making things happen it
seems to be a lot of what's happening
with my man musk these days yeah he
seems to be one of those people who
realizes that if he just slightly over
promises then he can get people
including himself to work harder yeah
like he was like we're gonna be done
with the Tesla Model 3 in July and he
was like look we finished one I didn't
say I said ah not tha ah that's right
it's a huge difference between uh and
Hank the news from AFC Wimbledon is that
a contractor has been announced oh well
do you know how when you build a
building like a building okay yeah a
contractor has been announced for the
new stadium at plough Lane
Andrew Scott limited which built Stoke
city's stadium there in the Premier
League now so I don't know if there's
necessarily a one-to-one correlation but
let's we could keep our fingers crossed
they are going to be they are the
preferred contractor for the new stadium
at plough Lane really really exciting
news because as each of these little
steps forward it becomes more and more
likely
indeed there will be a new stadium in
Wimbledon's historic home maybe even for
the 2019 2020 season meaning that AFC
Wimbledon are gonna be back home at
least eight years before humans will be
on Mars and probably ten years or maybe
even fourteen sixteen forty oh god yeah
I mean at this point you live to see a
person on Mars head at this point I I've
just I hope that I live to see human
humanity discontinue to get better in
lots of different ways and whether
that's our understanding and exploration
of our solar system and universe that's
great but also just take care of each
other
and being nice and not naik not driving
not driving humans apart and making them
angry at each other all the time
Hank real quickly I just have to break a
little bit of political news to you
people listening to this will be
listening to it of course in the future
when all of this will be known but I am
about to tell you something that you
don't know which is that Donald Trump
has just fired Anthony scarran Moochie
after eight days as White House
communications director in deeply
shocking news oh my god that is amazing
eight days Hank well you know John I'm
not I'm not sad about it no I don't
think I don't I will not miss him
although I would like some continuity in
American you know John you know what I
want I want to have never known that
that guy exists yeah that would have
been great but that's not how it went
down Hank what did we learn today that
you can't keep track of this and like
you just can't the other day my mom said
something about Corey Lewandowski and I
was like who because it's just there's
too many of them and this is actually
it's just it's it's it's something of a
strategy to have like to have these news
cycles be constant I think it must be a
strategy because it's really effective
in a way like I I have a lot of friends
who've published books in the last six
months and there's a
rule that you never publish a book in
there like six months before an American
presidential election because you can't
get any media to cover it because the
only thing that the media is talking
about is politics and the genius of
what's happened in the Trump
administration I mean you can say a lot
of bad things about it and and we have
but the genius of it is that it has
taken that six months before
presidential election and extended it
infinitely so now you also can't get any
media attention for your new book
because for any are too busy talking
about the events of the day well because
the events of the day are always
perpetually dramatic in astana yeah
and dramatic in is the grit is the word
because it's not it doesn't necessarily
have a significant effect on things but
it is dramatic and it is it is sort of
amazing and it's not just it's it's
everything like there in previous years
we've had the ability to like win a
famine on the level of the one that is
happening right now in Sudan could get
some traction and there's just no space
for it nobody's right but it's a space
to talk about cholera and Yemen there's
no spit yeah no that's very true and
yeah it's true for every news story that
doesn't start Donald Trump today comma
yeah you know it's it's a weird time but
we also learned that Oscar's Oasis is a
children's television program with no
words I learned that I have a feeling
that you you knew that quite well we
learned that you got a friend bucket
John and you don't want to slosh it too
much but you don't want to not slosh it
at all we learned that it is not okay to
put your shows in someone else's Netflix
queue no no and we learned that Kathryn
and I should probably have separate
Netflix account or thingies so that it
knows when to show up that good ol vicar
from Dibley and when it knows to show me
what I would have watch which is mostly
just nature documentaries Hank this is
gonna stun you because it stunned me
mm-hmm
are you ready is it more about the mooch
oh no no it's that there is actually no
English place named Dibley it is a
made-up place name which seems so
unlikely because all English place names
sound made-up but the village of Dibley
actually is made-up why didn't they just
pick one of the amazing actual name no
joke why didn't they just pick like
Hertfordshire land bottoms or whatever
yeah way oh god nothing matters thanks
for listening to your Hank and John if
you have questions you can email us at
Hank and John at gmail.com we apologize
for making the Trump media inundation
worse by mentioning him here at the end
of the pod that's that's our bad but you
can email us at Hank and John and
gmail.com your emails are always welcome
and appreciated I also have to apologize
because of course by next Monday when
this comes out this is gonna be the
oldest news that ever have 27 27
high-ranking White House officials will
have been fired in the interim Anthony
scaramouche II will have been fired for
longer than he was hired by that point
Hank before I let you read the credits I
just want to rosianna just sent me a
tweet from a sarcastic Rover the Mars
rover who is professionally sarcastic
who tweeted Mars is so far away from
Earth that we only just heard about
Sierra Moochie getting hired as
communications director congratulations
I'm sure everything's going great this
podcast is produced by rosianna halse
rojas and sheridan Gibson it's edited by
Nicholas Jenkins a Victoria Bongiorno is
our head of community and communications
and it handles all of our patreon stuff
you can go over and check our great
patreon where you can see that Vicar of
Dibley tattoo and also did dude get in
his head shape and if you want to email
us that's at Hank and John at gmail.com
we are on Twitter John's John Green I'm
Hank green this music that you're
hearing is by the great gunnarolla and
as they say in our hometown don't forget
to be awesome
you
[Music]